the longest anyone's gone without
laughing is been like ten jokes let's
see if you could beat that alright so
here we go try not to laugh okay okay
you ready
don't laugh have you seen Forrest Gump
yes I can't I can't do it I can't do a
camera that's the bigger problem
alright alright you can just look at me
okay I'm gonna look at you oh yeah now
it's to be easy I don't have you I have
you know what his facebook password is
what one Forrest one it's pretty good
get to the camera what is the traffic
light say to the car what don't look I'm
about to change
what is the rubberband factory workers
say when he was fired what oh snap if
your cheese with no cracker what are you
alright crackalacking
I think your crackalacking
I'm gonna do it I'm afraid why did Snoop
Dogg always have an umbrella I don't
know - the raining cats and dogs no food
drizzle ah sauce why good drizzle okay I
tried so hard
who's the smallest basketball player who
ever lived your mom
what's the chiropractors favorite dancer
oh no no joke because it works what did
the traffic light say to the car I don't
know don't look about a change
[Music]
why don't candle tremors one fourth
Monday through Friday Donna did they
only work on what games
make it very long today
what's the magician's favorite dance
[Music]
no abracadabra
have you heard of the movie constipation
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I want to know okay have you heard of
the movie constipation no what is the
traffic light say to the car don't look
I'm about to change
have you guys seen the movie Forrest
Gump
what's his facebook password
okay I'll tell you it's one forest one
will you call a guy with the rubber toe
Roberto
[Music]
why did the shrimp keep all his treasure
he was being a little shellfish what did
one hat say to the other you stay here
I'll go on ahead
why was the sand wet
whose near the ocean no because the sea
weed how do you make a tissue dance no
idea you put some boogie in it good you
put some boogie in it actually like
that's a q1 yeah yeah what do you call
it guy with the rubber toes I don't know
Roberto
what is one hat say to the other I don't
know you stay here I'll go on the head
would you call upon you with the cough
what a little hoarse
did you hear about the superhero who
looks a lot and has a list now he's Thor
what did one hat say to the other I
don't know what you stay here I'll go on
the head it's a good one would do cause
we're under their pants what Thunder
pants
why didn't the shrimp share any of this
treasure why he's being a little
shellfish finally thing my I'm gonna get
back we call it be on the bad hair day I
don't know frisbee
[Music]
did you hear about the superhero with
the list that always works out what's
force gums Facebook password Jenny
no it's one forest one why wouldn't the
shrimp share his treasure stripper
greedy he was being a little shellfish
hey I like shrimp is this like magical
for what's a musical chairs where when
you laugh you get kicked out and whoever
you can do that yeah yeah Chuck you
laugh you have to leave yeah okay okay
here we go
[Laughter]
have you guys seen the movie for stuff
yes do you know what his facebook
password is forest one forest one
one forest one get it what did one hat
say to the other you stay here I'll go
on ahead
I like the dollars you're not supposed
to laugh what did the traffic light safe
of the car stop no he said don't look
I'm about to change what uh what did the
rubberband factory workers say when he
got fired what a snap he said oh snap
why this noob dog always carry around an
umbrella I don't know why I don't know
have you guys heard of the movie
constipation no how's it come out yet
okay that's not fair yeah we laugh at
them laugh okay why was it Dan wet it's
all washed out because the seaweed
okay if your cheese with no cracker what
are you your crackalacking what do you
call it be on the bad hair day frisbee
why wasn't the shrimp sharing any of his
treasures he's being a little shellfish
because here's why I am so used to
listening to bad jokes that I can get
him that's the problem really here the
bad jokes hey guys thanks for watching
another episode before you go the most
important thing I want to tell you guys
today is thank you seriously I don't
think I could ever thank you enough
because of you guys I'm able to share my
work with more and more people every day
I really I just really appreciate that
and I hope you guys know it
[Music]